black Mira Bandersnatch is the gift that
keeps on giving this Christmas after
offering a unique experience for viewers
that comes in the form of a
choose-your-own-adventure TV show the
program too gets a bit like Inception
with one of its mega secret endings
whilst it's unclear exactly how to
trigger it and no one has any concrete
answers just yet many viewers have
encountered it when unpacking one of
banda snatches many endings the scene
itself seems pretty dull and most people
probably think that it's just a replay
of an earlier scene as often happens in
Bandersnatch but there is a bit more to
it
we joined Stefan on his bus journey to
tuck a soft entertainment but instead of
pulling out the two music tapes he
instead pulls out a Bandersnatch one the
tape plays a crazy noise that sounds
like a cross between the radios from
Silent Hill and an old dial-up modem
which is a bit confusing but some super
savvy fans discovered that the data is
actually the same as a tape for a ZX
spectrum computer which is what Stefan
designs and plays his games on after
people run the code through a spectrum
emulator they were given a QR code
scanning this takes you to the tucker
soft website which contains info and art
for their games clicking the sidebar tab
that has nose dive on it allows you to
go to a page for the old spectrum game
this page allows users to download a
full copy of the game that is free to
play till their heart's content or the
one controlling us at netflix decides to
tip tea over the computer you'll need a
spectrum emulator to play it but it's
such a cool little easter egg that
showcases the extent of just how far the
creators of the show went with their
hidden endings so what are your thoughts
on the super secret ending of
Bandersnatch did you enjoy it and what
did you think of the show overall
comment below and let me know and I've
left a path that seems to be successful
on how to get this ending in the
description so make sure you read that
if you want to experience it for
yourself if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my original
Bandersnatch video which discusses all
of the choices that I made and how if
could my outcome this is a channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]